Hello, everybody.
Hi, hi.
The Blade Runner.
John Blade Runner.
McCoy.
That guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Howdy, howdy.
Yeah.
How are you gonna defeat them?
With my... with my... Blade.
I studied.
I think I have to... I just realized.
I think I have to... move the game over.
We'll see.
The guy behind you has a gun.
Well, I've got... these guns.
Brandon, happy birthday!
Okay, Blade's birthday.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Gamershop Minto shirt arrived.
I'm so ready to Mint Max.
Thank you for getting it, pal.
Thank you.
Um... I studied the Blade.
I got your waifu cup.
Wow, thank you!
It's my birthday today.
Soberguy, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
It's Mothra's...
64th birthday tomorrow.
Well, happy birthday.
It's basically you.
Happy birthday, Mothra.
Yeah.
Um, I... I actually...
I looked up a walkthrough.
Hold on, let me get it ready.
I have...
I have three tabs of walkthroughs open at the moment.
We'll see if any of them work.
I actually don't remember...
Where...
I don't remember.
Currently watching the stream of my new Bito shirt.
Thank you for...
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Getting pumped for MGS Con.
Do you have a panel?
Whether you join karaoke or only enjoying...
We're still discussing, actually.
Everything that I am doing.
I think I have several things I am doing.
So if you go to MGS Con...
You may see me several places.
Oh no, the music.
New cup, shirt, and mat.
Thank you!
And I thought...
Since you're like big...
Robots...
Just can't lie.
Have you heard of...
Megaton Musashi?
Sounds familiar.
Arigato, arigato.
Choo!
I'm lonely.
Can you fix that?
Anyway, hope you are doing well today.
I can fix that with a stream!
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
Imagine like hanging out...
In stream and...
You know...
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
Wait!
Oh my gosh, you're right!
YouTube did fix the names!
What is going on?
What are they thinking there?
Why are the names changing every other day?
I'm so confused.
I'm so confused!
When I first saw your stream, I honestly didn't know what to expect, but over time, you've won my heart time and time again.
Will you be my Oshie?
Oh my gosh, Brian!
I'll think about it!
Once you declare me your Oshie, you can't change.
Yeah.
Think long and hard about it.
I'm doomed, then.
Been real sicky.
Eris!
Feel better.
This is a treat.
Back to lurking.
Oh, okay.
Get better.
Kami Oshie.
No, no, no.
It doesn't have to be Kami Oshie, but just Oshie.
Forever.
Yeah.
So, shall we?
Shall we get back into it?
Our girlfriend is a wisp now!
She said that you're sweet for asking me about her and said we should both propose to you when we intend to be angry with you.
Sulkin, did I just steal your girl?
Mr. Steal Your Girl?
Mid-Fent-O-Wisp.
Wait a second.
It's the subject of dreams.
Wait, what do you mean subject?
What did we talk about dreams?
From last stream, I have reoccurring dreams where I find a weird building in my neighborhood that I don't remember being there.
And almost every time it ends up being a food court.
Are you hungry?
Are you going to bed without eating or something?
Anything?
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Why the mouth sensitivity is so bad?
Alright.
Where?
Where did we...
Okay.
Hysteria Hall.
I know that.
What did we end up...
Oh.
Okay, I do remember I went in here and then I got shot at.
So, currently... Currently, we are on the run, baby.
We are running away from the cops.
I guess... I think it's that they think we're a replicant, no?
Watching Mint on... Mint on Company time.
Let's go!
I got your Game Recepts Cup on my birthday.
Yay!
Thank you.
Thank you so much for getting it.
I really appreciate it, you guys.
Thank you.
Shooty... Yeah, we're gonna shoot, probably.
We might be a replicant.
Oh, yeah, they think that we murdered the Katana guy.
That's right.
Uh, Izoy.
Izoy.
Izzy.
That guy.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
And... We are... Um... Yes, we are on the run.
So... Inzoy!
Izoy?
No.
What's his name?
What is his name?
Hmm... I don't remember.
But, um... Okay, hold on.
Animal murderer.
Oh, golly.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
I wish there was something that I could, like...
Give us a, like, a... Hey, this is what you should be doing.
There's something about the moon bus we gotta do.
That can't be me.
Yeah, we are at the moon bus.
We might be a replicant.
Guys, if we're a replicant...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna go...
Rambo style on everybody.
It says, I'm so... Thank you so much for the thank you for the...
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Um, there's this guy.
He murdered, um...
Eisenduller, who was the guy in the anti-gravity.
And... Oh my gosh.
There's, like, a freaking fly around me.
Go away!
Um... Hmm.
And then...
What else?
Moon bus.
Alright, let's go back to...
Okay, one thing I do wanna see is if...
Okay, we were trying to talk to Lucy before.
I want to see if we could talk to her.
I also don't remember...
Is this where my car is?
I think we don't have my car.
So I'm a little like...
What are you calling me stinky for?
Is it because I've been running around in the sewers...
And I'm disgusting and sweaty?
I need to ask you...
Yeah, I need to ask you what I'm doing.
Okay, where was my car?
Great question.
I don't want to get anywhere that I need to go.
Hold on.
Maybe this guy knows anything.
Like I said, I have walkthroughs open.
I don't know if they'll be useful.
Pour me one.
Just one?
One but one good one.
Yeah, but one good one.
I flubbed it.
One but one good one.
Okay, he doesn't know anything.
He just wants us drunk.
Cops hate this one simple ghost.
Click here to find out more.
Yeah, click the subscribe button.
Cedar, thank you so much for the five group to take.
One but one good one.
Do you know anything?
Thanks for your time.
Literally nothing?
Okay.
How?
What about in here?
Do you think he's going to attack me?
Because I'm...
What's that word on the...
The land?
Be on the lookout for Ray McCoy.
Last seen in the fourth sector.
Subject is armed and extremely dangerous.
No, I'm not extreme.
Oh, shoot.
No, no.
Scum sucking skin jobs everywhere.
What just happened?
I died of cringe.
What happened?
Did he shoot me?
My
God.
Link forgot him.
No.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you are really Moe Mothra.
Okay, this is the nightclubs.
Remember, we got sexy ladies up here.
It looks like a half bra.
And then you got ladies inside the boobs.
Crazy.
That's some crazy work.
Okay, our car is not here.
Where do you...
Okay, hold on.
I'm just going to load.
Excuse me.
I'm loading.
Look at my game.
All right.
We know not to go through there.
Okay.
We died.
We definitely died.
But I'm not quite sure.
Maybe I do need to shoot those cops.
To get anywhere, maybe.
It's time to go...
They were in here.
I'm almost positive.
Where does this go?
Unless they're over...
If I right click to get my gun out...
It stops me from...
Oh!
I didn't go this way, did I?
Okay, never mind.
I think maybe I went into that other area...
Too...
Just be in a safety zone.
Dude, what happened?
Everything all right?
I died of cringe.
Okay, hold on.
No, I am going to get my gun out.
Okay, here we go.
I'm ready to shoot.
Ooh.
Tasty.
Okay, so this leads up.
Where does this go?
Okay.
And then we have this door over here.
Is that all we've got going on around here?
Can I drink the bath water?
Let's go over here.
Mountain Dew water.
I put on my wizard robe and hat.
Shut the hell up.
Why are you even saying that?
All of this looks so familiar.
But, like, I don't remember why.
I feel like there's, like, a shootout in here or something.
This...
Is there anything here?
Hello?
Nowhere?
Okay.
Well, at least we...
What?
What is here?
Okay.
I...
All right.
So we will go out the sewer this way.
And see where we end up.
I'm on the run.
It's...
I said...
I'm on the lam.
Is that what I'm thinking of?
I am Pingu.
Welcome to members of the Hingu.
Oh, I remember.
I was going to move the game over a little bit.
I'm so sorry.
You guys, give me a second.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
I'm on the lam.
Okay.
What's up here?
I don't know where I am.
Wait, isn't this just the hotel?
Is this the hotel?
I'm home!
Oh, no.
They're going to be waiting for me, huh?
At my...
Apartment.
At my apartment?
Roof.
I think they're going to be waiting for me.
My dog!
McCoy, 88F.
Wait, my dog.
Maggie!
Thank you.
Uh-oh.
Is my dog okay?
Where's Maggie?
Where's my...
Where's my animal?
My dog, motherfucker.
Ain't no Maggie here.
She was here last night when I left.
You got the wrong place, Jack.
What?
Hey, man.
I live here.
I don't know what your speed load is.
And I really don't care.
Wait a minute.
I got no problem icing you if that's what you want, Jack.
My name's not Jack.
Um.
Give me your floor number, please.
They kicked me out of my house!
Apartments.
Maggie!
Oh, my God!
Wait, do you think if I go back, he'll yell at me?
Or he'll kill me?
McCoy, 88F.
Destination, loft.
Strange.
Your floor number, please.
Apartments.
Roof.
Destination, loft.
You won't let me even go to the roof!
What?
Roof.
Oh, my God.
We can't even go to the roof!
No way!
Oh, my God.
But it's...
Wait, does it still say McCoy for the apartment?
Does it still say?
Your floor number, please.
Roof.
It does.
Freaky.
Where's our dog again?
Let's go to the police station, I think we can, from this way?
Wait, why would we want to go there?
I don't think we want to go to the police...
I don't...
I don't know where else to go!
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to save real quick.
Wait a second.
19...
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, I have to start saving from down here.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess we're going to go turn ourselves in!
Was Maggie a hallucination?
No!
Maggie was real!
Talk to the guy who asked if you killed anyone.
Yeah.
That guy...
I think he's a little...
I think he's a figment of our imagination.
Locked!
You can't just lock the police station!
Wait, what do you mean it's locked?
Locked.
No kidding!
What?
Officer, please!
I have an emergency!
What's going on?
Locked.
Tried to turn myself in, but they were closed.
Yeah, I guess I'll come back tomorrow.
Wait, where the heck am I supposed to go then?
I can't go to the...
I can't turn myself in!
I can't even go to the roof!
Where's my car?
I don't remember where I parked it!
Oh, man!
Trap...
This sewer travel is really...
Bumming me out.
I think...
There has to be something in here, no?
Jarvis, check the bar.
They probably took our car, I imagine.
We never got to talk to the girl.
I can't remember her name.
Amy?
Lucy?
Lucy.
Let's find the turtles and have pizza.
Cowabunga!
Sinar, thank you so much for your five more gifted.
Thank you.
I can't find anything in here.
I can't.
This...
Goes back.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go fight some cops.
Let's go shoot some coppers.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I messed with the wrong McCoy.
I'm gonna save right here, though.
Ha ha ha ha.
Before we do.
Wait, is this the one that I just saved?
What did I just save?
Oh, it's moving it up here.
How fun.
Wait.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the date.
Yes.
Okay.
I got my guns out.
Let's go.
Let's shoot.
One shot.
One kill, baby.
Oh.
Wait, the police are gone.
Hello?
They were definitely here before.
I remember.
Wait.
Oh?
Okay.
I'm running.
Can you imagine how wet his socks are?
Whoa.
That was audio, by the way.
Wait, where'd the cops go?
I was so ready to shoot.
Wait.
Let me get my gun out.
Okay.
I'm ready to shoot.
And I mean, though, I'm just gonna keep listening with my eyes closed.
Until sleep takes me.
Good night.
Good night, good night.
What's in here?
Oh, spooky red.
All right.
Let's go in.
With my gun out.
I'm ready to kill.
Where's my dog?
This is subtly turned into...
This is subtly...
John Wick.
Hey, another one?
Have you ever heard of private property?
John Wick.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, buddy.
Oh, he's got the pizza.
Wait, while we need her, the turtles.
He's got the pizza.
Can I shoot?
I can kill this guy.
Holy cow.
I'll talk to him.
Oh, I can't talk to him.
Oh, yes, I can.
Hey.
Haven't I seen you somewhere before?
Have I?
Hmm.
Always chasing.
That your name?
Chaser?
Chaser.
But that big, dumb locks out the back of the sushi bar, remember?
Ow!
Small world, ain't it?
Hmm, guess so.
Guess so.
And again, I ain't the one standing in your living room.
Well, um...
Uh, others.
You've got another one, when I came down the elevator.
Not a lot of people.
Artificials.
How'd you know they were replicants?
Are you kidding?
I can spot a skin job at a hundred paces in the dark.
Describe them to me.
You don't got that drink?
Drink?
Maybe later.
Well, there's the Japanese guy with the coat and the glasses.
Skinny guy, blonde hair, ponytail?
Yeah.
And, uh, the guy with the muscles and the funny hair.
Who?
Dreadlocks?
Right, I've seen him twice.
And a two-headed guy, the fat man.
Fat man?
The one I was chasing from the sushi bar.
Nah, the other fat man.
You know him.
The Metal Gear Fat Man.
Oh, it's the fat man.
Fat man honestly belongs in this series, no?
Fat man!
Laugh and grow fat.
How many times have you seen the fat man down here?
Bunch of times.
Last time weren't that long ago.
The fat man.
What was he doing?
Collecting guns like always.
Handguns?
A blaster like mine?
Handguns, rifles, a whole armful.
Took them through that gate.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Dumped them in the sewer.
The sewer?
Here go now.
Sure you ain't got nothing to drink?
Can you describe him?
Yeah, rough guy.
He bucks out orders a lot.
He's got roller skates and he's rollerblading.
Let me ask you something.
Cooked it be.
Damn tasty.
Does he need a drink?
Oh!
Bring me looking good.
Hey wake up!
Let me ask you something.
Wake up!
He's asleep.
He will never hear from him again.
KFC!
He's got them chicken wangs.
Wait!
Are we gonna die over here?
Okay.
Wowee.
This looks like a pretty...
Like a boss fight of a room, no?
So the guns are in here?
This is from OG Fallout.
This looks like it's from Fallout.
No kidding?
There's nothing else we can do in here, so...
Okay.
We can go the other way.
That...
Well good.
We came in here and we got to talk to that guy.
Very cool.
I'm Fat Man.
I like the lighting here.
Even...
The game is very...
You know, like this is...
A video game of Blade Runner and it's so cinematic, no?
I wanna walk out in the middle and reveal my plan.
Right?
I was thinking like some guy would come out and be like...
Haha.
I think I've got you gut.
So I'm gonna tell you everything.
Where did the cops go?
Maybe they left because now we can act...
Before we weren't supposed to go this way.
And now we can go this way.
Maybe today is the pizza party at the...
At the...
At the cops...
At the police station.
And so...
Okay.
So over to the right is the hotel.
I can't remember where I was trying to go.
Oh.
Maybe that's why it's closed though, you know?
Just gonna save over this one.
Actually, we'll save over this one.
Peace.
Okay.
Pizza party.
Kinda nice.
For sure.
Have you seen my dog?
You seen any suspicious types around here lately?
And my dog?
Ali, that's all I do see.
You think this is a club met or something?
Okay.
Very helpful.
Thank you.
Hmm.
Wait.
What did I get?
Nothing.
Oh.
Way to get my hopes up.
McCoy, come on.
Wait.
But how do I go upstairs?
I cannot anymore.
Oh wait.
Uh...
Oh, how was that?
McCoy looks lonely.
If he finds the pizza party, will it fix that?
Absolutely.
I'm trying to remember.
Actually, I remember how to get back into that one room.
I'm just kind of exploring everywhere around now because I'm like...
Also, there was a car here, no?
A crashed car?
It's gone now.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
I thought this was an opening for something, but it's not.
Oh!
Is that a bird?
Wow.
Pizza fills the void.
It dies.
I think he says, yuck.
Totally uninteresting.
Never mind.
This is not disgusting to him.
Okay, this goes into the hotel room that we had gotten kidnapped in.
If you guys remember.
Yeah.
And we saw...
Okay, you don't need to keep doing that.
We saw Lucy here.
Pizza!
Are those cheeks?
Nothing else there.
Okay, well, I guess there's nothing else here.
You found the mo- Oh.
Sorry, I made a big old loop table.
Oopsie.
I have no idea what I'm supposed to be doing.
I'm so confused.
But we're...
I think this goes...
into...
that area we were just in.
So, no...
going...
no need to go back there.
Let's go talk.
Do you think they've cleaned up the mess at the sushi place?
I sure hope so.
Wow!
Where does he get this gunk from?
Is he taken from the sewer?
Hello?
Is there anybody that can help me with where I need to go?
I'm so lost.
You!
McCoy, LPD.
McCoy!
That's me!
I'm LPD!
Excuse me, pal.
Excuse me, pal, please!
Everybody's my pal tonight.
I don't think that they...
I think this restaurant might be a front.
Do you know the song Be Sweet by the band Japanese Breakfast?
Is it okay if I request that one for the next karaoke?
Um...
I don't know it, but I can look into it.
Thank you, Matthew!
I'll try to remember, but I might forget.
Cause I'm playing the game.
So thank you so much for the super chatting!
Hound has a real green goop problem.
I just...
Well, maybe it's not a problem because apparently you can eat it.
So...
Um...
Okay, now I actually don't know what to do because...
I can't go home.
I feel like all of my options are...
Wait, how did I get out of the sewer?
Uh...
Where did I come from?
Oh, wait.
I think I remember.
Right here.
I think there's another route on the screen with the three cops.
Three cops?
Excuse me, pal.
Love you, Mickey.
Thank you.
This screen?
I don't think so.
Doesn't seem to be the case.
We went downstairs and there was definitely nothing down there.
This way went to...
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
What was it?
Where did this go again?
Something about guns in the sewers.
Yeah, there's apparently guns in the sewers, but...
Okay, so this goes back to the nightclub, if I remember correctly.
Yes.
Oh, Miss Skyroom.
Was there a path to the ride?
Was there?
Did I miss it?
I'll go back and check, since I'm completely out of loss right now.
Completely out of loss.
Look all around, checkin'.
I love the green... green glow of this area.
It's not even just like a little bit of a green glow.
It's like... it's like the Simpsons green.
It was this one, yeah.
Like, this place is really infected.
Maybe there's like something I can touch, I don't know.
Radioactive, RADIOACTIVE!
RADIOACTIVE!
I'm a Blade Runner!
I'm lost in the game!
I don't know where to go!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Oh, more goo!
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
Good find.
Good eye.
Okay.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh!
I got...
I couldn't even just die to the rat house.
I had to fall into the goo.
Holy cow!
Okay.
Um...
This is the last...
Well, we didn't really get...
This is the last one that I saved though.
So we'll just do this one.
It's not that far.
Oh my gosh!
Looney Tunes!
It's the insult to injury!
It was just terrible!
They're like, look, I'm rag!
You're getting attacked!
Okay.
Alrighty.
Now I'm prepared.
I have my gun out.
Oh...
I thought this was a serious game, huh?
Nice.
I'll let your stream allow me to sleep.
Goodnight!
Okay!
Hello, Minto!
My G-subs Minto merch game today.
Thank you for ordering it!
Thank you, thank you!
That was karma for krilling the rat last stream.
You know what...
It might actually be.
Alright, here we go.
Guns out.
I'm ready to shoot.
I thought it was suspicious when...
He stopped on the bridge.
Alright, here he is.
Oh!
Dang it!
I...
Wasn't sure where he would...
Sorry.
I wasn't sure where he would stop.
Okay, I'm ready now.
Maybe I'm ready.
Actually, I'm kind of frightened.
Oh!
What am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do here?
I definitely shot the rat, though.
We had collabed with Camilla the other day.
It was so fun.
Oh!
Thanks for watching it!
I had a lot of fun with her.
Okay, hold on.
Die!
Okay, I don't think he's...
Maybe I run off the bridge.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Run!
Oh!
I like how he just kind of shows up.
I have to wait.
Hold on.
I'll wait for him to chase me.
Oh!
Okay, it's not possible.
Huh...
The hell am I supposed to do here?
Does he want pizza?
Is this truly my karma?
Rat, too.
I mean, that is a really big rat, so...
Okay, hold on.
Look, you sound lively.
Did something good happen?
I shouldn't sound lively.
I'm dead.
But...
No, nothing...
Nothing particular.
Hmm...
Maybe I...
Run past the rat.
What...
What would a rat want besides cheese?
I don't know where to get any cheese.
Maybe...
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I don't...
You know, like, maybe I don't...
Leave, I...
Hold on.
Um...
You sound deadly.
Something good happen.
Wait!
I do have cheese!
Remember?
Wait, I have some cheese...
I have cheese!
Wait!
I actually have cheese!
Wait, how do I give this to him?
How do I give him the cheese?
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I don't...
Ugh, this is gonna be tough.
I'm gonna click on him instead.
Cheese!
This is so stupid!
Hold on, I'm going to my walkthrough.
I'm gonna look up rat.
Rat.
Okay, one out of sixteen.
Give me a hug, rat.
Okay.
From now on, wander the sewers with your gun drawn, because rats will be lurking and they kill you!
Wait!
Okay!
Rat's bridge!
It's literally called that!
Halfway across the bridge, a huge rat will approach.
If you shoot the rat on the bridge, his weight will make the board crack.
And it's death for you.
I found the easiest way to kill the vermin is to walk slowly down the bridge.
Gun drawn.
When you freeze, it means he's about to appear, so quickly run off the plank to the side.
When the rat follows, wait until he's not touching the board, then put a bullet in him.
What?!
I saw I really...
Okay.
Gun drawn!
So maybe I, like, come over here, you know?
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Go.
McCoy, walk.
McCoy, walk over here.
Can I walk with my gun out?
Yes, I can.
Okay.
Walk.
Okay, I have to do this.
Now run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Whoa!
Yeah, we took care of that sucker!
Yes!
First try?
Just a moment of your time, please.
I am sick and tired of people waving those things around.
Just give it up.
You got no jurisdiction down here.
What's the twins?
No, no, we tried that already.
Look, we know that the adenine thymine and guanine cytosine sequences can be mutated in progress.
Let's move on.
Hey, it's about time you showed up.
Hey!
Do you know who I am?
Detective Ray McCoy.
Ask me.
You're investigating Miraji's death.
And Eisenduller's.
Having any luck?
You're Luther and Lance?
Hell of a smart cookie there.
Take your guns and your violence elsewhere.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have had my gun drawn.
Are you angry at me?
Sorry.
No, no, no.
I don't have my gun drawn.
Uh...
I thought that said pizza.
Congrats on beating possibly the hardest boss in the game!
Are they conjoined?
Yeah, they are.
Let's ask about...
What was that?
Clovis set me up, didn't he?
And he used my boss to do it.
He's sharp this one.
No question.
Tell me what you know.
How about we trade?
Our life for yours.
Wait, what?
Keep talking.
Clovis has gone to see Elden.
But he might not make it.
Still, the work will go on, with or without Clovis.
Clovis.
Get us Tyrell's files, the rest of the DNA data, and we'll help you.
You want me to break into the Tyrell building for you?
You're nuts.
Defective, yes.
Nuts, no.
You need us, McCoy.
We can serve up Guza's carcass on a big oversized platter.
We have to break into the Tyrell building?
Exciting.
Wait, who's that?
Ooh, a baby should be in that pod.
I like how we're just...
Are they gonna invite us in, or...?
Um, replicates.
The reps that killed Marcus and Miraji, they'll be looking for you.
You're a little late, detective.
They've already found us.
So why are you still walking around?
Cause we're all part of the same pseudocards, you know what I mean?
Oh?
Well, Elden makes mistakes just like any other... human.
The difference is...
The difference is, your bastard doesn't like to admit it.
No, he covers them up, pretends they're human, gives them a job at a stinking corporation, and then when they actually produce original work, he boots them out on the street.
You're saying... you're replicants?
We finally figured it out.
Clovis helped us see the light.
But that's ridiculous.
Hyrule wouldn't design something like you.
Damn!
That's perfection.
I told you we were a mistake.
No!
Keep talking.
Sometimes our memories are... different from each other's.
The implant process isn't perfect.
We know, we've seen the studies.
You can't always be sure exactly how the memories will play out in the subject's mind.
We're totally a replicant.
We've got different recollections of our childhood.
Explain that.
Maybe one of you just forgot.
If you can't trust your own memories, what's left that makes you human?
Maggie!
Because our own apartment wasn't even... wasn't even right... I don't know.
Oh, gosh.
There's a lot here.
Okay.
There's so many... hold on.
Wait.
Okay, I'll just ask him.
What are you doing down here?
Elden shafted us, so now we're returning the favor.
We promised Clovis we'd be finished with this by the time he got back, so if you don't mind...
Okay.
Oh, that's not what I meant to say.
Um...
So this is Sadiq.
That's us.
Izo.
Lucy.
That is Clovis.
That's the big bad guy that we've been after.
I guess... what was it?
Mr. Eldon Ring.
He is the guy at Tyrell.
I guess he's like the big baddie at Tyrell.
Our apartment did say McCoy.
It did.
Nobody tell them how memory is malleable.
Yeah, no one tell them how eyewitnesses are so inaccurate so many times because they just forget everything.
They remember what they want to remember.
Lifespan.
Tyrell says the four year lifespan can't be extended.
Of course he's gonna say that, but he's wrong.
Very wrong.
We got the research right here that'll prove it.
Wait, so if I had a digital girlfriend, she would...
Could you extend the life of a replicant right now?
Well, no.
If I had a replicant girlfriend, she would only last four years?
The four year limit is an integral part of every element of the replicant.
Tyrell's dictate was that every body part would fail, and only the designers of each would know exactly how it worked.
Clovis has already unlocked a secret of the skin.
That was Miraji.
Sebastian and Chu, they'd know about the central nervous system in the eyes.
A lot of retrograde viruses were built into the eyes.
And Tyrell, he's got the basic DNA pattern information, but he won't just give it up.
Did you tell Clovis all this?
He didn't ask.
He already knew.
He knows all about you, too.
Does he like me?
I think that doesn't know.
Chu.
Chu was that one Chinese guy that was in the ice cube.
Yeah, I remember him.
He was right before the guy.
Minto, are you the real McCoy?
I don't know anymore!
Clovis.
Where's Clovis now?
Gone to have a little heart-to-heart with Elden.
Elden Ring.
He'll kill Tyrell if he gets to him.
Isn't that just too bad?
Oh, Tyrell's the big guy.
I won't shed any tears.
Tyrell is killing us all.
Is it Tyrell or Tyrell?
Please pick one.
Four years isn't enough, is it?
If Clovis snaps his neck, it'll be merciful and quick.
That's a hell of a lot more than we've been given.
Elden Ring.
That's...
Oh my gosh, wait.
Elden.
The Dawn.
Oh my gosh.
Is Elden Ring about... gangsters?
The Dawn.
Elden Ring.
I got a little test I want you to take.
You believe this clown?
He wants to Voight Confess.
Oh!
Oh, I completely... I forget what this is every time.
Sorry, McCoy.
Shoot us or leave us alone.
I forget what the Voight...
Let's get back to work.
I forget what that is every time.
What kind of deal did you have going with Runciter?
Don't talk to me about it.
That was Lance's stupid deal.
We just wanted to make some extra cash on the side.
We only got to do that one time, but it was kind of...
I'm sure he wasn't too pleased.
I didn't understand it at all.
Since Elden is such a pain in the ass control freak.
Elden Ring.
Did you meet Clovis through Runciter?
It was all just a coincidence.
They are really chill.
I like them.
Okay, I'm gonna save here so we don't have to go through all the dialogue again.
Makeshift bridge.
No, that was the rat bridge.
Okay.
And then we have...
Oh!
We can go up or we can go in.
Let's go in.
Oh!
Wow!
And we can go up.
We are so great.
I don't feel so good.
What's up here?
Rude but chill.
Oh!
They're gone!
They were in the Matrix.
This is where we are!
And so this is where Chew is.
Phil, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
This was where the explosion happened.
Wait, can we even...
There's probably nothing in here.
Wait.
It was green.
For a moment.
Locked.
No way through here.
I don't think that's locked.
I think that's exploded.
And then from here, we can get to, um...
Oh, the puppet man?
Is my car here?
No.
I think my car is gone.
My car is...
Done-zo.
Locked.
Wait, really?
We can't go see Chew either?
There?
This is where the...
The puppet man is.
And, um...
Yes.
There was something too.
Something down here, no?
What was down here?
Wait...
Oh my god!
That's the...
That's the sushi place in the hotel.
Apartment?
I keep calling it a hotel.
It's probably an apartment complex.
Okay.
Now we have...
To go up those one stairs.
That ladder.
Everything is looping.
Oh, they're back!
Stick around.
I may not be finished with you.
They're like, Shut the hell up, McCoy.
We don't care.
In here.
What?
Huh?
Whoa.
No, no.
Wait, huh?
All of this is right here?
Okay, we go here.
We're teeny tiny.
We're gonna be crawling through the vents?
What are we doing?
No!
Oh!
Oh, it's a sneaky mission.
We just snuck into Tyrell.
I'm gonna...
Kill that guy.
Wait...
Oh, I can't.
Come on!
Oh!
Hey, yo!
Stop!
Oh!
I got the achievement.
Not so coy after all.
Get thrown in jail.
Hey, you!
Stop!
Come on, let me kill him.
Let me kill him.
He's right there!
What if I just...
Go.
Oh!
It worked!
What is that?
A phone?
Why are we in Egypt?
All of a sudden...
What are these wind chimes?
Hello?
I'm so sneaky, you guys.
Oh.
I got something.
What did I get?
I don't know.
Not the answering machine.
Oh!
I got the DNA!
We got the Tyrell DNA!
We can just leave.
I'm sleepy.
Can we do Blade Runner?
Watch a log sometime.
Yeah, that would be fun!
Tyrell really sucks at his job.
This was too easy, you know?
Uh,
bye!
I got what she wanted.
No boxes required.
Yeah, give me Guza!
Your boss is a real piece of work, let me tell you.
Almost as good as Tyrell.
Let's take a look.
That probably had something to do with you guys getting fired.
Guza had his fingers in as many rancid pies as possible.
He was insatiable.
He sold police equipment, ripped off criminals, and he even killed.
And here were documents that proved it all.
Oh my god!
Depositions, photographs, video discs.
Wow!
It was the complete file on Guza, the dirty cop.
Where'd you get this?
From Clovis.
He told us to hold it for him.
Oh.
Come to think of it, I'm not sure you're supposed to see it.
You wanna give it back now?
No.
Not a chance.
Let him have it.
Clovis said he was finished with the policeman anyway.
A little light started to flicker in my brain.
Guza was the one measuring me for the frame.
Oh.
When my stomach stopped churning, I realized I had everything I needed to force the bastard to play ball with me.
I knew that he would listen to reason, if applied with serious pressure.
All I needed to do was call him.
The guy?
Do I have his number, or...?
Surely in 2019 we had cell phones, no?
Save?
Oh yeah, don't you worry, I am.
I'm kind of curious to go back to the Tyrell building.
It was...
It was too easy.
Okay, um...
Stick around.
I may not be finished with you.
Okay, uh...
Where did the...
Oh, this went this way.
Alright, we gotta go find him.
I remember...
Fighting him in...
It was like...
Oh, I remember as a kid...
Maybe it was the police station you fight him.
I don't know.
How do I get back to there?
This thing is gonna laugh at us.
So creepy.
Wasn't there a phone here?
Was there?
There's a phone here...
Oh, you're right!
There is a phone in here!
Yeah, cause we had the answering machine!
Huh?
I don't understand your super chat, but thank you!
I've gotten all I can from that.
Wait, no, that's the phone...
That's the...
Maybe here?
Oh!
Yeah?
Been messing with people's lives lately?
McCoy!
Where the hell you been?
We've been looking all over for you.
Yeah?
Am I wanted dead or alive?
You don't know what you are, kid.
You can sell that replicant shit to everybody else, but I ain't buying.
If you're so clean, let's put you on the machine.
That'll decide once and for all.
I'm through listening, Guza.
Now it's your turn.
I've been doing some investigating on my own.
Came across some prime sources.
You know what I'm talking about.
Those little illegal weapons deals with Izo.
Izo!
You were raking in the chinions, selling LPD wares to scumbags and reps.
Oh, yeah.
The department's gonna eat it up when they hear just how deep that corruption goes.
That's a load of crap.
Crap.
Let's hope for your sake, Bryant and the brass field that way, when I lay this file on them.
Otherwise, it's a one-way ticket to the off-world penal colony, fat man.
What do you want, McCoy?
Remove the frame, clear my name, and get that guy out of my apartment.
I want my life back.
I can't do that.
You better start finding a way, cause I got another call to make.
Okay, okay.
How do we work this out?
We can't talk over the damn phone.
The sewers.
The sewers!
I know you want to be comfortable, and I figure it's kind of like your second home down there.
I'm calling him a rat.
From the bottom of the old elevator, there's a gate.
Past it, there's a chamber.
It's got a round platform.
Oh, yes, yes.
Yeah, I know it.
Be there, alone.
And you better hold up your end, or Bryant gets it all.
Ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho!
I...
Stick around.
I may not be finished with you.
I like the way he points at them really dramatically.
Alright.
We're gonna go through here.
I will save...
Here.
Okay.
Save?
Um...
I'm gonna do a new one.
New, new.
Okay, here we go!
I'm gonna get my gun out.
I'm going in.
Luckily this was, like, so close.
Oh my god!
He's actually there!
Fat man!
Did you get that asshole out of my apartment?
It's cleaner than when you left it.
My dog?
The Maggie?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, your pooch is there too.
Is that everything I need to clear me?
I gotta tell you, kid.
Those inset photos look pretty real.
Let me guess.
Clovis gave them to you.
It must seem pretty gullible, but he sounded on a level.
Did he photoshop me?
She called you his brother.
Said you came down to the moon bus with all of them.
We're right at the moon bus!
He said Tyrell was using you to get inside the LPD.
Oh...
You hadn't been on the job too long, so I thought...
Maybe.
Oh...
You'd screw with my head?
How convenient.
You could satisfy your blackmailer.
And keep me from sniffing around your dirty work at the same time.
You're too smart for me, kid.
Water under the bridge.
You ready to talk trade?
Don't get closer!
What are you doing?
I got it all right here.
Photos, files, discs, the work.
It ain't a pretty sight.
You can't blame a guy for trying to better himself.
He's gonna throw us into the goo!
Trying is one thing.
Ripping off speed loaders and selling the shit yourself.
Farming out LPD weapons through black marketeers.
Torching two pimps who wouldn't pay you off when you were working vice.
Thanks.
Hey, those two had it coming.
You're recording all this, right McCoy?
How long did you think it could last?
You're recording?
Yeah, you're getting like evidence.
It finally reaches the point where you don't even think about what happened yesterday.
This does feel like a trap, yeah.
Only what's coming to you tomorrow.
I'm nervous.
20 years in the job, kid.
And nobody was gonna touch me.
Helping reps also part of the job?
Mm-hmm.
I was gonna whack them myself once the heat was off.
Tie up those loose ends.
Once I was out of the way.
Clovis is still gonna come gunning for me, kid.
You and Chris gotta take him down.
Then my problems are over.
Our problems are over.
And we can all live happily ever after.
Clovis.
Stop walking towards him!
He's gonna push us into the...
I don't know.
A lot has changed.
Oh my god.
I don't know what I want.
McCoy, please!
That's fine, kid.
Just walk away.
I knew you didn't have the cojones.
Hey, I got you where I want you, don't I?
Kid, I'm what they call a survivor.
I'm a survivor!
You're sick as sludge of hell and live to tell the tale.
Now we can tell.
I'll be around long after they've forgotten that you were ever on the job.
Wouldn't bet on it.
But I'm tired, kid.
I'm ready to turn over a new leaf.
I swear to you, everything will be different if we just stick together.
And knock the team out.
Oh.
Come on.
What do you say?
I see we were right to follow him, Sadiq.
Oh my god, it's Clovis!
Looks that way, man.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, shoot.
You might as well give it up, Clovis.
You and your people don't have a chance.
Hold on.
Save.
What if I shoot him right now?
That'd be crazy, though.
We stand a greater chance of success than you, Lieutenant.
McCoy and I were just talking about how to get you guys out of your jam.
What if I shoot him right now?
We came up with a plan.
But you gotta show yourself first.
We gotta do this in person.
Who the hell do you think you're kidding, McCoy?
Give it a try!
Oh, damn!
The hunter?
Do us a favor, man.
He bagged us a trick.
Do it!
Brother, you killed a human.
Brother!
Come out and show yourself!
First things first.
You must decide where you belong, brother.
Are we deciding with the replicates?
Oh my god!
You've wasted much time already.
No more choices, Ray McCoy.
Well, let me move around.
Meet us at the moon bus.
Together we will face the tiger that waits in the night's forest.
Brother!
I saw that one guy run down here.
Wait, I don't know how to get to the moon bus.
Can you give me the directions, please?
Hey.
Anybody know about a moon bus?
You?
You know about a moon bus?
Let me ask you something.
Yeah, about a moon bus.
Damn.
Never mind.
Oh.
Moon bus.
The arcade?
I haven't figured out how to get back there.
I'm not gonna lie.
Huh.
I always wanted a brother.
I haven't thought about that in a hot minute.
Wasn't it past the nightclub?
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
I can't get out!
Ah!
Where are you at?
Why do they always disappear?
Where?
Oh my god.
Oh!
There he comes!
He was right there!
Coming for me!
Did you see that?
He was coming up behind me!
Holy cow!
The sewers come out.
Okay, this is...
Where is this?
I actually have no idea.
They're out for blood.
This is...
Um...
Okay.
I know where this is.
Now we go back in here.
Oh, hi girl.
Yeah, that was Izo's place.
I'm trying to...
Okay.
Go back...
Maybe...
To the nightclub.
Maybe it was this one.
If we can get to the arcade from the nightclub.
I haven't been able to figure out how.
Ah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Anybody know where a moon bus is?
Wait, what was this way?
I don't remember.
There was one sewers that we could get to the car shop.
I thought...
Oh my gosh, what a run.
Ah!
Yes!
This...
Okay, wait.
This does go back to the arcade.
It was right here, right here.
Actually, can I go further down?
To the moon bus?
No.
No moon bus.
I've been trying to find this place the whole time.
And yet...
Here we are.
We found it.
Thank you, guys.
I want to see if Lucy is back here because I scared her off before.
Fight the rat.
No!
Oh my gosh.
Crazy.
Okay, in here.
Hysteria Hall.
No!
She's still not here!
This might be a mistake.
Okay, it was a mistake.
I'm trying to find the moon bus.
I have no idea where it is.
If I run around in circles.
I will just lose my head.
Where's the moon bus?
Where's the
moon bus?
Where's the moon bus?
Okay.
Lead runner... What?
Actually, no, I'm gonna... I'm just gonna lose my computer.
Where?
Yeah, instead of my phone.
Hi, da.
Huh?
Run back to my apartment.
Oh, wait.
I have to go back to my apartment?
But this is the bird bus.
That's what the walkthrough says, at least.
Start act five.
I thought we were on act three.
What did we turn to act four?
But Maggie... Yeah, maybe we gotta go back because he was just like, yeah, your dog's there.
Yeah, everything.
Can we take a car?
That would be really nice, right?
I... I'm
gonna see if I can steal a car.
Car, then we can go everywhere so... so much more quickly.
I think act four started when he got framed.
Oh, okay.
Howdy doody.
Let's go.
Take this one.
That sucks.
No, it doesn't.
Please.
Locked.
Please, it doesn't matter what it looks like.
No, maybe we can talk to him and say, hey, my car.
Please, mister.
I hope you get paperwork for all these vehicles.
Are we kids or what, Ray?
You're talking to crazy li- I take- You can take- Okay.
I keep your paws off that, Ray.
He sounds so disappointed in me.
I don't want to disappoint him.
Oh, we're going downstairs.
Do you think he's rotoscope?
I feel like the movement is so smooth, you know?
Why is he being picky all of a sudden?
This one's eggy.
I don't want it.
Oh, now I have to remember how to get to my apartment.
I don't remember which part of the sewers it was.
Oh, my gosh.
Bye.
Okay.
Mocap?
Oh, that's what I meant.
Sorry.
I said rotoscope.
I'm on mocap.
Yeah.
Which way?
Okay.
This is to Izo.
This is to Sushi.
And to where we shot the guy.
This game did use motion capture.
So, yeah.
That makes sense.
Wait.
I thought I saw a rat.
This one was...
I don't remember.
Let's go this way first.
I think rotoscope makes more sense for the time period.
Did they even have motion capture back then?
I'm sure.
Where does this go?
Tough day, McCoy.
You could say that.
Steel is looking for you.
And Bryant.
You've been keeping the whole department hopping.
You and Guza.
Guza.
I know.
You looking for me too, Gaff?
Looking.
Not killing.
I'm in a good mood today.
Oh.
You know you got some interesting neighbors, McCoy.
Oh?
Yeah, well.
I've been too busy to visit lately.
You're going to turn yourself in?
Hell no.
I'm thinking about it.
Wait, what?
Think hard.
Ah!
He's coming up on me!
You killed anyone yet?
No.
It's like I said before.
You retire a human, your career is over.
Wait, wait, wait.
Your life too, maybe.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I can't do anything.
It won't let me.
But we don't live forever, do we?
Logan, thank you for the five gifted.
Wait!
Do I have to kill that guy?
I didn't save.
What was the last one?
This one?
Oh my gosh.
It was literally when I was about to shoot that guy.
How?
I think I have to shoot.
I think I have to kill that cop like so fast.
Yeah, I said it before killing Guza.
Yeah, yeah.
This is it with this one.
We stand a greater chance of success than you, Lieutenant.
What if I don't shoot him?
He's got a gun though.
He's going to shoot me.
McCoy and I were just talking about how to get you guys out of your jam.
We came up with a plan.
But you've got to show yourself first.
We've got to do this in person.
And if I told you that Sadiq has a pulse rifle trained right at your heart...
Oop!
Without me, you for sure ain't going nowhere.
Let's see what happens.
Yeah, let's hear him out.
Let's hear him out.
We have everything we need.
And that doesn't include you.
Oh, I think he's about to die.
Too bad that we're becoming such good friends.
See ya!
Whatever is born of mortal birth must be consumed with the earth.
But he's still standing.
Derives from generation free.
Then what have I to do with thee?
Shoot him again!
Kiss my ass!
I missed the part where that's my plan.
So, what should we do with this detective?
It's been so persistent.
So it doesn't.
Yeah.
Wait, what do you mean it's over?
No, don't shoot me.
Oh, they're leaving?
I can't...
Wait, is he shooting at me?
Ow!
They give me two...
Ah!
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
That guy's gonna die anyway.
We stand a greater chance of success than you, Lieutenant.
I don't think we should kill him.
McCoy and I were just talking about how to get you guys out of your jam.
Can you shoot him while he's running?
We came up with a plan.
Maybe.
But you gotta show yourself first.
We gotta do this in person.
And if I told you that Sadiq has a pulse rifle...
I bet you can shoot him while he runs past.
That would be crazy!
Without me, you for sure ain't going nowhere.
If I leave and come back in...
We have everything we need.
And that doesn't include you.
Oh.
It won't let me leave.
Too bad we've become such good friends.
Whatever is born of mortal birth must be consumed with the Earth.
I was gonna save so I don't have to hear it all over again, but...
Then what have I to do with thee?
With thee!
Kiss my ass!
Bye, Batman!
So.
Okay.
What should we do with this detective?
Alright.
I'm gonna try and shoot him when he walks past.
You know what I would do to you.
Perhaps you're right.
Okay.
It's over.
I don't know where he comes from.
Oh!
I missed him!
Okay, run!
Run!
Well, I did shoot...
Uh...
I got in two hits.
Do you think he's still there?
Why am I so slow?
Like, I'm not even in any rush.
I was just getting shot at.
I don't care, I guess.
I think they're gone.
I think they're...
Well, we're not in trouble anymore.
Let's save a different save.
I guess we're not in trouble anymore.
So now let's go back to my apartment.
We're not going to the moon bus.
I don't even know where that was!
I didn't even know!
Also, how would they know that I shot and killed Guza, huh?
What a...
What?
I think he just was calling my bluff.
I think he was bluffing.
And he just killed me anyway.
Get me out of the way.
I don't know.
Nice save rotation, right?
Okay, where was it?
I'm making sure there's no rats around.
Um...
Okay.
What the?
You're making me very unhappy.
Oh my god!
What's happening?
Wait.
Oh.
Hey, what's happening?
Am I dead?
Get me out.
Get up.
Get up, McCoy.
Ah!
I'm sad!
It's damned if you do, damned if you don't!
What the hell?
Why did we just stand there and let...
And take it?
Why did we just stand there and take it?
It...
It gave me the option to shoot, but...
I...
It didn't turn red, so...
Okay.
I will have to shoot really fast, I think.
This guy...
This guy can't stop killing me.
What if I just leave really fast?
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Yeah, see?
I don't know what he's doing here.
Alright.
Shoot him, shoot him.
Shoot him, shoot.
See?
It like...
Oh, see?
As soon as he walks past...
Ah!
I can't get, like, a good...
You have to shoot the knife he used to pin your shadow down.
What the
heck?
This game is...
This is so wild.
What if we...
Wait, what if we go in here?
What if we go see the twins?
Hey, buddies.
A little help here.
A little help.
Stick around.
I may not be finished with you.
Okay, never mind.
Alright.
I don't know another route.
I don't know what to do here.
This game is...
Whack.
If I go this way...
Oh, they're gone now.
Go out here.
He's restraining you with his vampire telekinetic powers.
I don't understand it at all.
Onyx, thank you so much for five months.
Thank you.
Locked.
You gotta leave before he turns the corner.
Oh, maybe if I, like, run away real fast.
Should we try it one more time?
It's very confusing.
I keep forgetting that's an option.
I could just leave.
Maybe he chases me through the sewers.
That sounds so scary, though.
How do I get home?
Uh...
Trying to remember.
We can just leave.
We can just go.
Locked.
Oh, they're back.
We shall figure it out.
I believe.
Was it La...
Laugh to Ryder?
Ha, I thought I don't remember.
Alright.
I try to leave.
And...
He...
Does...
Whatever the hell is happening here.
And then I leave.
I leave.
Go, go, go, go.
Ha ha ha ha.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Run.
Run, Mikoy!
Run, Mikoy, please.
Oh, no time to dilly-dally.
Chilly-shally.
I went the wrong way.
It was down.
It was it?
Okay.
Thank you.
Well...
This guy's not after me anyway.
I think we're safe.
I'm not making him that sad, apparently.
No!
No, this is Izoi.
It wasn't down.
Unless it was the other down.
Ha ha ha.
East?
I thought you meant weest.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
This down!
Oh my gosh.
Good thing we're not getting...
Um...
Followed.
Okay.
I think it's...
This way.
Ha ha ha ha.
This is so...
It gets so confusing.
I wish I could...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm gonna keep my gun now.
What if we get double-crossed?
Tough day, McCoy.
You could say that.
Yeah.
Steel is looking for you.
And Bryant.
Don't shoot me.
You better not.
You've been keeping the whole department hopping.
You and Guza.
I didn't kill Guza.
I know.
You're looking for me too, Gav?
And if he tries to kill me here, I will shoot Guza.
Not killing.
I'm in a good mood today.
I will.
You know you got some interesting neighbors, McCoy.
I got my gun out.
Yeah.
Well, I've been too busy to visit lately.
You gonna turn yourself in?
I'm thinking about it.
Think hard.
You killed anyone yet?
No.
It's like I said before.
Wait.
You retire a human, your career is over.
The policeman didn't...
Your life too, maybe.
You didn't run out.
We're safe.
But we don't live forever, do we?
The policeman didn't run out and shoot me.
Oh.
We're safe.
Very good.
Act...
Act 6.
5.
Act 5.
At last estimate, 5 billion tons of kippel surround this city.
Eventually, it's going to have to be cleared away.
Elden.
We've got specials...
Oh, it's Elden.
But the attrition rate is enormous.
No, no.
There's only one way it can be accomplished.
Why do they dress like this?
Unfortunately, your way is illegal.
For the moment, yes.
The laws can be changed.
And if replicants were allowed to work on Earth, imagine what your legacy would be.
Governor Maurice Colvig, the national hero who eliminated toxic debris.
Uh-oh.
The glasses shining like that.
I don't know.
Can you possibly guarantee that no tragedies will occur?
It's a very simple solution to an old design challenge.
Phil Knight, yeah.
Give them jobs on Earth, and they will never desire a different life.
That...
is a lie.
Yeah, that is a lie.
Who's there?
Oh.
It's one of my children, I think, and a very resourceful one at that.
Why don't you show yourself?
With pleasure.
Call security.
Globus!
Who is this man?
I'd like to ask the same question.
One more word from him, and he'll be dead.
I will not be spoken...
Oh!
You're certainly a man of your word.
I want all the data you have on replicating DNA structures, the mutation studies, everything.
Why don't you just take a seat?
We'll have a little talk.
I don't have time for talk.
I wish I could help you.
I really do.
What is happening?
What's going on?
The four-year lifespan is unalterable.
My friends, my family, dying before my very eyes, and all you can say is...
there is...
Time is precious, my son.
Mmm.
And you have been keeping yours well.
Can you guys speak up a little?
And when night comes, I'll go to place fit for woe, walking along the darkened valley with silent...
melancholy.
Oh!
Start your brain!
I would prefer him alive, if possible!
Oh, oops.
Who shot first?
Okay, was it me?
Ah!
Oh, my God!
Not exactly the conclusion I had in mind.
Can you station guards in the mezzanine?
Yes, sir, but...
I mean...
after that fall.
Oh, don't be a fool.
He's not dead yet.
His time hasn't come.
Maggie!
Come here, girl!
I just dropped my drink.
I jumped so...
Nothing.
Where's the phone?
Oh, my gosh.
Everything happened...
I didn't even have a chance to speak.
I was...
I was quoting...
Devil May Cry.
Suddenly...
Maggie!
Where's the phone?
Oh, my gosh, shut up!
Another retirement in the fourth sector today as a Blade Runner shot an alleged replicant in the middle of a crowded street.
Lieutenant Edison Guza, supervisor of the LPD's rep DTEC unit, had this to say.
It was a good, clean takedown.
The public should thank us for retiring these skin jobs before they get into any real trouble.
You want to get that thing out of my face before it ends up shooting film where the sun don't shine?
Oh, my God, please.
Pick up.
Where you been, Slim?
The boys told me you were kicked out.
Oh!
My dog is still missing.
Cut the crap about the dog, okay?
I got something that'll really rev your engine.
No, no, I'm not cutting the crap about my dog.
I got a line on where the skin jobs are hollin' up.
Not the Yukon?
Yesterday's news.
Remember Gap was talking about that food bus messager?
Maggie!
Found out where they crash-landed it.
Five will get you ten, they'll be licking their wounds there.
Well...
Excellent.
Where do we go?
What if the dog is the actual...
How about Mwah?
The actual evil.
It's way the shit out there in the kippel.
Way, way out.
How are they getting into the city?
They've been accessing to an old sewer tunnel.
Dog is priority.
Are we gonna air out the reps together, or what?
I kind of like McCoy.
He's so innocent in that regard.
He's just like, Maggie, we die.
First come, first serve.
I share my bonuses with nobody.
See you on the other side, Slim.
Maggie!
Maggie, I will find you out there in this housecape of a city!
If it's the last thing I do!
Maggie!
Should we sleep?
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
Why does he say that every time?
You have a...
You know you can take a nap.
You can sleep.
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
Like, that's...
That's you.
You do that.
Okay.
So where do we go now?
We talk to whatever her name is that was just on the phone.
Wait, what happens if we click here?
Nothing.
Nothing?
But you were supposed to give Maggie a treat here.
It's John Wick time.
Yeah.
Fortunate dogless world we live in.
Nothing.
It's a dogless dog world.
Your floor number, please.
Wait, can we go to the roof?
Roof.
Destination locked.
Your floor number, please.
Okay, we can't go to the roof.
Give me my car back, please.
I'm going insane.
Please give me my car.
Please.
What if I ask really nicely?
Is the police station still locked?
Locked.
Seriously?
Maggie enters carrying a gun in her mouth and points it at McCoy.
She speaks her clever, Raymond, but you've learned too much.
I'd rather not thank you so much for this 10 gifted.
Thank you.
She said to meet her somewhere, but I'm also just like, where?
Madam?
I have no car.
I cannot go to the kibble or whatever the hell it's called.
Hey, man.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
I can't go to the kibble.
What was in here?
Now we're back in the sewers.
This is like our second home at this point.
Wait.
This was not open before.
Oh my gosh.
It's a good thing I checked.
Let's go.
Oh my God.
There's rats.
I had to do it to him.
How do I...
Wait, what if I wanted to go home?
Okay, that doesn't seem...
There's only one way.
Is this where I came from?
No.
Oh, the lady.
Bad time you got here.
Steely.
That's her name.
If I was a Nexus 6, you'd be dead.
No, you'd be dead.
I heard you stumbling around back there 10 minutes ago.
I got a little hung up.
Where's the moon bus?
The moon bus!
No close.
You ready to take care of business?
Oh yeah, man.
Hell yeah.
It's gonna be a hot time in the old town tonight.
Hot dag.
I liked how the fog is...
The fog is giving rave.
I don't like it.
It smells like ambush territory.
Smells like sewer.
Oh, sorry.
That's me.
Two.
Oh, steely.
Always hated closed spaces.
Steely.
Hold on.
I'll get an ambulance out here.
I screwed the pooch this time, Slim.
Promise.
You'll waste Clovis.
Touched pretty well, didn't I?
What?
This is...
Nothing
in here.
What was the point of us coming in here?
Oh
my god.
No!
Wait, is that...
Oh, that's us.
Okay.
Where do we need...
We had a...
Oh, this way.
Just kidding.
Not this way.
Uh, the ambulance!
Someone...
Call an ambulance!
Okay, this is where we came from.
So we go this way.
Um...
This is where I just saved, right?
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm...
Save's coming a little bit.
I don't think there was a way to save her.
Where do we go from here?
I
don't think there was a way to save her.
The moon!
Maggie!
Come here, girl.
Come on.
Don't do it.
No, no, no.
No.
No, no.
Don't do it.
Don't you dare do it.
I'm searching.
Don't do it.
Please.
Please let my dog come to me.
Please let my dog get here.
Please don't shoot him.
Please, please don't shoot my dog.
Please don't shoot my dog.
Please.
Please, Maggie!
Maggie, don't fall from the rat.
Okay.
Please, Maggie, why did you... Please!
How could they?
Oh, God.
No.
You like my present month?
You bastard!
She was an innocent!
I'm a figma.
I'm a sheep, like you.
Tyrell, you make her more doggy than dog, you know?
That's a lie!
You don't remember it?
I'm taking none of it.
Them false memories.
They really worked you good.
Come on out and show yourself, you coward!
His reaction was too... Oh, there he is!
Oh, I almost got him.
Come here!
Come out, coward!
Oh, where are you shooting from?
Where are you shooting from?
Where?
Oh, my God!
I knew it was gonna happen.
But I didn't expect his reaction to be like... Oh, God, no!
Oh, no, Maggie!
Maggie!
Okay, alright, alright, alright, alright.
She was innocent!
Maggie!
The way she exploded!
Come here, girl!
Come on!
I can't!
Wait, can I run?
Okay, we can run to her.
Maggie!
Maggie, Maggie!
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
How could they?
Oh, God.
No.
You like my present, ma?
You bastard!
She was an innocent!
She's a big man.
A machine, like you!
Cyra, you make her more... doggy than dogs, you know?
That's a lie!
You don't remember it?
I'm taking...
No, no, Maggie!
Then follow the memories!
Please!
I don't want you!
Oh, wait!
Come on out and show yourself, you coward!
Wait, I need my gun!
Oh, shoot!
I don't have my gun!
Shoot him!
Oh, I got him.
I got his ass.
Nothing else there.
That one's for Maggie!
You bastard!
Holy cow!
Sorry!
I'm good!
Okay, we can go that way!
We can go this way!
Let's go!
Let's go this way!
Okay, sorry.
Sorry, Steely.
Anyway, okay.
Anyway.
Oh!
Is this John Wick?
Yeah, we really are John Wick now!
And he...
Nothing else there.
You click on his body!
I was expecting a yuck.
I'm not gonna lie, but...
Sheesh.
It's so funny.
The Moon Boss.
Are we gonna remember everything now?
Before...
You guys, before I go in...
I'm gonna go get some more water real quick.
I can't...
We fed her the tree and she's...
What if it was me?
What if I killed her?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna go get some more water.
What?
Okay.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I guess you know that we're endgame because everybody keeps exploding.
I can't stop laughing about...
About everything.
Everything that's happened in like the past 10 minutes has been so funny.
Did you feed Maggie a grenade, apparently?
Oh my gosh, that is the Eiffel Tower in the background, isn't it?
Wait, but we're in LA.
How is that possible?
That's the...
The...
La... La... La... La...
The LA...
Full Tower.
Wait, what's that movie?
Where you...
The Planet of the Apes.
It's Planet of the Apes right now.
There was an Eiffel Tower in 2019, LA.
Oh yeah, I remember that.
I remember that.
They had it just for 2019 and then said...
Yeah...
Yeah, we don't need this anymore.
Yeah, we're...
Whoa, whoa, yeah!
What if it's Tokyo Tower?
That would make sense.
Alright, let's go inside the...
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited to go inside the moon bus.
Scores!
Happy Birthday!
Okay, let's go.
Frequent flyer points.
Visit all locations.
Oh, Clovis is in his little blankie.
He's not...
I guess he's not...
Wait, I could shoot him right now.
Did I beat the game?
What a waste.
That one's for Maggie.
Wait, so if I just leave...
I guess I should have talked to him.
I see Steel didn't make it.
Oh my god, wait!
I could have used you about 10 minutes ago.
Let's see this through and then we'll do like the second ending, I guess.
See, Bryant wants to talk to you.
He says you're really ready now.
It never ends, does it?
Uh-uh.
You're a real Blade Runner now.
Full retirement bonuses and everything.
You've done a man's job, sir.
How come I don't feel good about it?
Uh, cause your dog exploded.
Who knows?
Buy yourself another animal, maybe.
A real one, not a Tyrell fake.
She wasn't fake.
Whatever you wanna believe, McCoy.
Oh, McCoy.
What is that?
Was that a Paper Maggie?
Oh no, it was the Ore...
Is this the origin of the Oregarmi Killer?
No kidding!
Completed the game on me.
Oh, wait.
We'll go back, you guys.
We're gonna go back and we're gonna talk to him for real.
But that can't be how it ends, Nona.
He was all tucked in.
He was ready for bed.
Oh.
Who made the...
The Oregarmi?
I wanna see what...
What...
What's his name...
Jarvis has to say.
I can't remember his name.
Clover...
Chovus?
Is it Chovus?
Oh, God.
Gaff makes origami figures.
Oh, Clovis!
I was close with Clover.
Ray McCoy, the man that you are.
Wait, there's a guy named Dino?
We missed him!
Oh, the French voice actors.
Oh, Philippe.
And Gerard.
And another Philippe.
And...
Yuck.
Oh, gosh.
I...
Kind of wanna see what happens if we...
Side with...
The...
Because there's the other ending where you side with the replicants.
Do not ask Mint to tuck me in at night.
Meet
at the moon, boss.
How did we meet...
What's her name?
Steely.
She calls us.
And then we go to...
Uh...
Wait.
One second.
Okay, there's a couple things I wanna do.
First...
I wanna go in here.
And we'll talk to him for real.
I've been expecting you.
Yeah.
What are you reading?
They're all dead.
You're the last one.
I wish I could just leave.
Just power up this ship and fly away.
Is he...
Oh, his four-year lifespan?
There's no rest to do.
And no more time.
You want me to feel sorry for you.
But after what you did to Maggie...
No way.
So true.
And what about you, Ray McCoy?
He's just dying all of a sudden?
Oh, well, he did jump out that window.
Do you not also seek forgiveness?
I don't need to.
He's so eepy.
I thought I could cheat my destiny.
You killed my dog.
I should have cherished what little time I had instead of wasting even one precious minute on revenge.
Coughs in red.
My hands are labored day and night.
And ease comes never in my son.
Okay, Shakespeare.
Hurry up.
Wife has no indulgence given except what comes to her from heaven.
We eat little and we drink less.
Given and heaven do not rhyme.
This earth breathes not our happiness.
Another sun.
Oh my god, he keeps going.
We are not warmed with thy beams.
With thy...
Oh, I can just shut him up.
Look.
Oh, yet the space...
That I do see.
But my mind...
Is not with thy light arrayed.
My terrors...
Shall not make me afraid.
What if I leave?
Oh.
Oops.
I see steel didn't make it.
I could have used you about ten minutes ago.
You didn't need any help, McCoy.
Chief Bryant wants to talk to you.
He says you're really ready now.
It never ends, does it?
Uh-uh.
You're a real Blade Runner now.
This game is...
Full retirement bonuses and everything.
Making me sick.
You've done a man's job, sir.
How come I don't feel good about it?
Who knows?
Buy yourself another animal, maybe.
A real one, not a Tyrell fake.
A real one.
Okay, okay, whatever.
Whatever you say.
Okay.
Oh, I should've...
Now there's one last thing we want to do.
We want to try and get the other ending where we side with the replicates.
So...
Maybe that will save Maggie.
I think we go...
Okay.
I think we shoot the guy, then we go back home.
And then we'll get the call from Steely, I hope.
It's gonna be a long one?
Is it?
Is it a much longer ending?
We'll see.
We stand a greater chance of success than...
Who the hell do you think you're getting, McCoy?
You're gonna pry!
Blim, blim, blim!
And then I shoot him dead.
And then he says...
The hunter?
He do us a favor mind.
He bagged us a traitor.
Brother!
Then they say meet us at the moon bus.
You've killed a human.
There's no going back now.
Come out and show yourself.
First things first.
You must decide where you belong, brother.
Brother!
Stop calling me that!
Hehehehe.
Always wanted a brother.
You've wasted much precious time already.
No more choices, Ray McCoy.
Meet us at the moon bus.
The moon bus!
Together we will face the tiger that waits in the night's forest.
Tiger, tiger burning bright.
Okay.
Do you think they'll ambush my home?
Is the bigger question.
Alright, let's see.
Brother!
Ahh.
How did I get to the moon bus?
Maybe go to the moon bus instead of the apartment.
Oh, wait.
I do remember how to get to the moon bus.
So maybe I don't need to go home?
We'll try.
Wait, let me get my gun out just in case there's a rat.
This game has 13 endings?
You're kidding me right now.
I guess it has a bunch of endings depending on whether someone is a replicant or not.
This is to Izo.
Well, I'm safe to say I will not be getting all 13.
It was...
Here.
If we didn't go back home.
Let's see, let's see.
Ah, see, it's not open yet.
This was how we get to the kibble.
So, I think I do have to go home.
Some endings are just with different characters.
That makes sense, yeah.
Wow, good on them for making such an intensive game back in the day.
A few are mostly variations, etc.
But there's several uniques.
Okay, so this is where we get ambushed.
By...
Yeah.
I'm just gonna keep saving over.
This is where we get ambushed by the cop that tries to kill us.
I think we can try and just run inside.
Let's do that.
Tough day, McCoy.
Hello.
You could...
And the cops...
I'm thinking.
I can't... I don't... I hate this part because I don't know where my cursor is, you know?
Like I said before.
You retire a human, your career is over.
Wait, what?
Your life too, maybe.
Wait, where's the cop?
Uh...
But we don't live forever, do we?
Was that a... random event?
Wait...
Well, you should have voted for him then.
Very good.
Very funny, yeah.
Maggie!
Come here, girl.
Okay, no Maggie yet.
Alright.
Let's put my gun away.
No way!
That was a random event that the guy came?
But it was so serendipitous, it was like perfect timing!
No!
Where you been, Slim?
The boys told me you were kicked hours ago.
My dog is still missing.
Cut the crap about the dog, okay?
I got something that'll really rev your engine.
I'm all ears.
I'm so confused.
Not the Yukon?
Yesterday's news.
Remember Gap was talking about that moon bus massacre?
Moon bus massacre.
Found out where they crash landed it.
Five will get you ten.
They'll be licking their wounds there.
Excellent.
Where do we go?
We?
How about Wah?
Here's a hint, Slim.
It's way the shit out there in the Kittle.
How are the...
Okay.
We know how to get there.
Huh?
I...
This game is...
This game is blowing my mind right now.
I guess I'll save over it.
Wait, isn't it gonna be any different?
Well, they told me to meet them.
Yeah, it should be different.
Your floor number, please.
What if I go down there and I'm ambushed?
Ground floor.
Roof.
One last roof for the road.
Good job on ending one anyway.
Act five was quick.
Figured they'd also explode the coin in this car.
We never got to see our car again.
I didn't expect to be laughing at Maggie's death either.
But it was just so funny.
Gotta save Maggie.
Yeah.
I hope...
I hope this ending doesn't have her explode.
Let's hope for that.
And Steely, I guess, too.
Because, um...
Oh my god, wait.
Red, red, red...
Hello!
Bad time you got here.
If I was a Nexus 6, you'd be dead.
No, you'd be dead.
I heard you stumped.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Alright.
Yeah!
Alright, let's see how different it becomes.
I don't like it.
Smells like ambush territory.
I think she's gonna explode.
Stop.
Don't do it!
I can't stop her.
Oh, yes I can.
Wait.
What?
There's a trigger there.
See it?
And what's that blinking?
I stopped her!
Crafty little suckers.
Could be on a timer.
Looks like Sadiq's work.
Same setup as the one at the Rhett manufacturing plant.
Step around it.
We should clear it.
All this kiffle gives me the heebie-jeebies.
I need room to breathe.
Take a deep breath around here, you'll cough up a lung.
Oh?
Oh, wait.
What's that beeping sound?
Please don't explode.
Wait.
Is it gonna explode?
Oh.
Okay.
We're fine.
Maggie!
Come here, girl!
Come on!
What's that tide around her?
Oh!
Maggie!
Here you go, baby.
Dinner time.
How could they?
Let's attend to some business.
Oh, God.
No.
You like my present, ma?
You bastard!
She was an innocent!
I'm big, ma.
I'm a sheep, like you.
Tyra, you think I'm on?
Doggy the dog, you know?
That's a lie!
Where did she go?
None of it.
Them false memories.
They really worked you good.
Come on out and show yourself, you coward!
Where did she go?
Wait, what are you doing?
She went this way.
Ma'am?
Let's attend to some business in this...
Oh, my God.
Nothing else there.
Oh, my God!
Well, I guess we're getting a different ending because she's alive!
I'm finishing this alone, Steel.
No chance.
Steely!
The bastard killed my dog.
He tried to convince me I wasn't human.
Yeah!
The job ain't about revenge, McCoy.
If it's the money you're worried about, you can have it.
The name's Wick.
But I'm doing this one alone.
You're a stubborn son of a bitch.
Look, I'll give you two minutes.
That's all.
Are you gonna shoot me?
Oh, and she's off again.
I
walk in there very slowly.
I've been expecting you.
Hi, dog.
My dog!
My high dog!
It's a doggy dog world.
They're all dead.
You're the last one.
I wish I could just leave.
Just power up this ship and fly away.
But there's nowhere else to go.
I don't know.
I was kind of thinking about just sitting here and wondering.
Let's just let him yap.
Let's let him yap and see if she will come inside.
No way.
And what about you, Ray McCoy?
After what you did to my family?
My friends.
My dog!
Do you not also seek forgiveness?
I don't need to.
I thought I could cheat my destiny.
I should have cherished what little time I had instead of waiting.
My hands are labored day and night.
Okay.
And ease comes never in my sight.
My wife has no indulgence given except what comes to her from heaven.
We eat little, we drink less.
Maybe we don't need to wait for her.
I never did like poetry.
laughing
For a waste.
Awww!
laughing Okay!
Jesus, Slim.
I almost blew your brains out.
Do it.
You just might be doing me a favor.
Damn!
Yeah...
I think he got a promotion coming.
Not to mention all those retirement bonuses.
Do I have a lady friend now?
As long as I get something like 20 hours of sleep in the process.
Am I right?
I'm going home, Steel.
I'm finished.
Steely.
Our dog.
Hey, Slim.
What?
Oh, new ending.
You ever think of working with a partner?
I thought you only worked alone.
There's a first for everything.
I'll think about it.
I'm much better company than a dog, you know.
Oh, the little eyebrow raise.
Miss Steely.
Steely McCoy has a good ring to it.
Wait, her last name is Steel, isn't it?
Whatever, it's fine.
She can take them both.
Okay, well, we got a different ending.
You know what?
I'm...
I don't think...
I can't believe they still killed my dog, even after I sided with them.
Those bastards...
Maybe this is the good end.
Oh yeah, they banging.
Bink!
You can't save Maggie, unfortunately.
No!
The line.
I was never a fan of poetry.
What if you said your name in a creepy voice?
Wait, what?
Oh.
This is so silly.
This is so funny.
Can we fly the kipple?
I think the kipple is the area, no?
The kipple is not the moon bus.
Oh.
Is there an ending where everyone explodes?
We saved the girl.
If you enjoy these kinds of old school adventure games, you should check out...
Mystery of the Druids.
Easily one of my favorites.
Oh, interesting.
I do really like these.
It has such a charm to it.
And then also, like...
It just is so funny in the most random ways, you know?
Like...
His delivery after...
Us feeding the dog and it exploding...
It's so funny.
It's so, so funny.
Mystery of the Druids mentioned.
I think I've heard of it before.
I'm gonna look it up.
Camp Noir!
That's a perfect way of putting it.
Mystery of the Druids.
What is this cover?
Oh my god.
Holy cow.
It reminds me of playing those, uh...
Like, FMV type games.
Where they have, like, the real people.
Like, Scand...
Like, you know...
Camp Noir.
That's a great way of putting it.
Maggie exploded and you're laughing?
I'm sorry.
It was so funny.
It's such a good time.
I'll look into it.
I'll see if I can find a way to play it.
Oh no.
My retro gaming era is here.
But recently, I've been really wanting to play like, uh...
I don't know.
Like, some sort of adventure game.
Almost like an Indiana Jones-esque.
But like, third person.
I don't know.
I've been wanting to play something.
So many good point-and-click PC adventures.
Police quest open season gave me nightmares as a kid, but it's hilarious in my thirties.
I don't know that.
Yeah.
Like Uncharted?
Well, uh...
Yes, I could play Uncharted.
But...
I meant like, uh...
Gameplay.
Rather than...
The...
Than the, um...
But I do want to play Uncharted.
Maybe I should start that.
Hmm...
Let's go.
Where in the world is Carmen Sandiego?
I used to play that as a kid too.
Tomb Raider?
Hell no.
I played that demo of Tomb Raider.
If you didn't see...
I played like, a bunch of demo discs.
At one point.
And I played a demo of Tomb Raider.
And...
I can't...
I don't understand the controls at all.
It's...
It's too difficult for me.
My princess, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Dang, we only were like, two hours out.
From beating the game.
And I was a little slow.
I thought it might be a little bit longer.
But...
It ended up being quite short.
Have you ever played the Jack Trilogy?
I haven't!
Also, hi!
Hello!
I know this game is very nostalgic for you.
It was really good for its age.
Thanks for taking us on this journey.
Yeah, thank you!
There are parts that...
I...
Completely misremembered as a kid.
I think...
There are parts that I remember...
Shooting more.
Maybe my dad discovered things that I didn't...
I didn't discover.
Thanks for the super unintentionally silly game.
Thank you!
Too bad about Maggie.
But she will always remain...
In our hearts.
Through the lulls.
Thank you.
Do I go?
Implanted memories.
Am I a replicant?
Totally didn't show you the nightclub.
I don't remember the nightclub.
At all.
So I am very convinced that...
But I remember that pet shop at the very beginning.
Like...
Crazy.
I knew that was the first part that we were gonna start at the game.
Like I...
Like there were some parts that I was like...
Ah, I know this place.
I know this place.
So I...
It's not that I think I forgot.
When would I forget?
Ah...
Why would I forget?
An Indiana Jones adventure game, you say?
Well, I did do the one.
The most recent one.
Legendary classic Indiana Jones and the Faith of Atlantis.
I thought there were...
I didn't realize there were other...
Indiana Jones games.
I thought it was just Lego Indiana Jones from here.
Faith of Atlantis.
Fate of Atlantis?
Secret of Atlantis?
Oh, look it up.
Indiana Jones.
Atlantis.
Wait, the cover looks so good.
It looks like an actual Indiana Jones movie.
Ah...
It looks so good.
Oh, it's from 1992.
Wait, what kind of game is this?
Is it like a point and click?
Metal Gear Revengeance.
We'll get there.
I'll do Revengeance after...
After I finally get through V.
It's like this?
Wait, that would be so fun.
And it's Indiana Jones!
That sounds kind of fun.
King's Quest 7 for point and click.
I...
Wait, that game also sounds familiar.
Oh, wait.
Wait?
Nah, I don't think I played it.
But I do recognize it.
Hmm.
Ah...
This is so fun.
There's so many games I gotta play.
Luckily, we have lots of time.
We got lots and lots of time.
More games like Doom.
I still wanna play the new Doom.
The...
Medieval one.
Playing Revengeance?
Nah.
It'll be really fun to play Revengeance now that I know everything.
Because when I first played Metal Gear Rising Revengeance, uh...
I hadn't played any of the other Metal Gear games.
So...
For me, it was just like a hack and slash.
Like...
But...
Um...
Now it'll be actually like...
I...
Know what's going on, maybe.
So...
You'll get to meet Split S...
Split...
Don't call him that!
Don't...
Sam...
Actually invested in the story.
I know!
Will you play Snake's Revenge?
I plan on it, eventually.
Yeah.
Ugh...
I've...
I actually was struggling because I was like...
I was like...
There's...
I wanna start a new series so bad...
But I...
Completely blanked out on everything that I was wanting to play.
Minus like...
Obviously Metal Gear V and...
Death Stranding.
Just trying to find good timing for those.
Hmm...
We'll do karaoke session in the chat.
Yeah!
Wait, his name is Split Stream Sam, isn't it?
Now that I think about it.
Oh yeah!
Wait...
It is?
Not right.
Am I...
Blanking out?
No!
It's Jet Stream Sam, you assholes!
I'm gonna leave.
I'm leaving!
You guys...
Yes...
I'll...
I hate you all.
I hate you all!
Ahhhh
Oh Tamita!
Thank you guys...
For watching!
For hanging out with me...
Except, no thank you.
I'm deleting the VOD and I'll redo... I'll redo Blade Runner.
It'll be like it never happened.